tous sont environ 15 enfants en france
depuis la mi avril qui présentent une
maladie qui ressemble à ce qu'on appelle
la maladie de kawasaki
les européennes ont observé un premier
des cas de jeunes enfants contaminés par
l'aco vide qui présentaient des
symptômes semblables à ceux d'une
maladie inflammatoire rares et parfois
mortels normalement la maladie de
kawasaki touche à peine un enfant de
moins de 5 ans au 8000 surtout des
garçons elle cause de ce ver
inflammation de la peau et des artères
et dans le pire des cas des problèmes
cardiaques
mais depuis le début de l'épidémie on
voit un peu plus de cas qu'à l'habitude
dans les hôpitaux à 6 pour attirer
l'attention des experts jusqu'au québec
par rapport aux années précédentes à la
même époque on ne voit pas une explosion
de cas où il est absolument impossible
de dire ça mais d'établir un lien de
cause à effet entre ces symptômes là et
l'épidémie providence moment ça serait
très important le dr haddad a lui même
observer plusieurs cas inhabituels de la
maladie en général les enfants qu'ils
attrapent fond de la fièvre ont des
éruptions sur la peau on la paume des
mains enflé et d'autres symptômes
typiques du syndrome les cas inhabituels
se présente seulement quelques-uns de
ses symptômes
est ce que le corona virus en serait la
cause c'est possible on pense que dans
la maladie de kawasaki c'est une
réaction immunitaire exagéré un stimulus
extérieur pourquoi pas virale pour
l'instant aucun enfant ne serait décédé
de ce problème
n'empêche l'organisation mondiale de la
santé prend affaire très au sérieux
foued club au micro nationaux de rodez à
sainte justine on a mis sur pied une
équipe pour suivre les cas suspect à la
trace la bonne nouvelle dans tout ça
c'est que même si c'était lié aux
qu'ovide d'après les informations qu'ont
à nos collègues européens qui ont réussi
à vraiment faire à démontrer le lien
dans certains cas l'évolution est comme
d'habitude sous traitement ça marche ici
normand grandin radio canada montréal